hello my name is markiplier and welcome
back to one of the most satisfying games
of all time
power wash simulator there's been a
number of updates because the last time
that i played this was september of last
year i think and also there's apparently
multiplayer now so if i can somehow rope
in bob and waiter sean or anyone else to
play this with me
i'll do that the mayor's mansion god
that's not a lot of money is that even
going to be worth it i guess it doesn't
really matter what's worth it it just
matters what i do and how i enjoy it
look at that look at the handle look at
the squeeze on that bad boy that's
pretty cool i don't know how they've
changed any of the um mechanics of soap
or anything like that i'm just going to
get into this because i do enjoy
clothing
i don't customize career mode mayor's
mansion
resume also they they had like some
controls okay i'm done
[Music]
[Laughter]
i guess i did it
i'm the best that was very satisfying i
supposed
power washer i've just joined the
traveling carnival pitching up at the
recreation ground you may have seen us
purchase a beautiful classic carousel
but i'm worried about being outgunned by
the owners of the bigger rides it's
pretty filthy i was going to clean it up
myself but then i thought hey what would
happen if i gave her a deep clean and
really made her pop who'd want to slowly
slide down a grubby helter skelter when
they can waltz around a pristine
carousel right make her ping and we'll
both clean up you'll arrive in a plane
van right don't want the competition
getting the same idea
okay whatever man
i'll do it
oh
[Music]
okay
oh god no
damn it i didn't mean to start
i didn't mean to start
i don't even know
wow r to rotate the nozzle i saw in the
patch notes i saw that they put that in
wait no i got to show you the patch
notes because it's it's just like i know
what they're trying to say here and um
it's their fault not mine and they don't
need to be sassy because i
don't deserve that kind of sass tutorial
pop-ups appear the first time you play
in point nine and we hope it will help
new players get the most out of the game
the first time they play maybe some
content creators won't be stuck
realizing they can rotate their nozzles
over multiple episodes
it wasn't obvious why would i think that
you could do that why would anybody
think that you could do that it's
obviously that wouldn't be the thing
that it would be twitch nozzle
um i really don't know how soap works
properly here
um
multi-purpose cleaner stone cleaner
plastic cleaner i don't even know what
this is
metal it's mostly metal but the middle
ones are plastic so if i were to have
none of these because using these are
practically cheating
and i stick with what i know
let's try this all right how do i do aim
mode jump
dope love that
show dirt okay that's also cheating aim
mode
ah
oh i can finally stand still oh that's
so nice
cheating i would officially consider
that to be cheating whoa
uh let me not have this extender
here we go
well let me not have that extender at
all
there we go
uh let me go ahead and do uh yield 15
degree and i'll focus on the top and the
bottom first ah nah that ain't gonna
work either i'll just uh i'll keep the
old green and i'll just go for this
maybe i'll do it in two blasts
yeah i'll just do it in two blasts
i see you couldn't do this
couldn't do this uh kind of skilled
cleansing if you were uh
not aware of the mechanics of the game
you don't need no tutorial to tell you
how to turn a nozzle i wouldn't even
need to turn the nozzle you don't need
to turn a nozzle here i'm not bitter
about it i'm not bitter about anything
i'm not bitter about this or me or you
or anybody
anyway
the one good thing about this game is
that it leaves me an opportunity to talk
about things since i haven't had a
chance to do that it's kind of like a
podcast i mean i imagine there's
probably a good idea here to have a
podcast based around just the co-op
version of washing these
various machines you just invite someone
in and you're like let's talk about [ __ ]
while we uh power wash something
and honestly that might actually be a
good idea for podcasts i'm laying
copyright to that idea anyone that takes
it you need to pay me money
that's how that works uh so wow yeah
it's been a while
i am uh
space is out space has been out for a
while people have enjoyed that if you
didn't know in space with markiplier is
out and um you know now that people have
gotten to see through part two and all
of that
is done it's it's crazy to think about
and it's it's fitting i think to talk
about it here because i kind of talked
about the end of filming
with the last time that i played this
it's just one of those things where
to look back
and i was talking to that one i was just
so happy of of being able to make
something cool and now that it's
actually out and i'm so proud of how it
came out and i'm so proud of all the
work that other people have put into it
you know i'm able to say with full
confidence that you know
i really accomplished what i set out to
do and and i'm so
so damn proud of it it's one of those
things i constantly say i look back at
other projects that i've done and i can
pick apart the problems that i didn't
did uh with them but it's not like i'm
not proud but this one is like
man i really see how far i've come
in terms of like
a creator
like someone who is able to turn uh
their vision in their head into a
reality which is
all we really do is creators are artists
or anything like it all boils down to
being able to see something in your head
and only exists in your head and putting
it out into the world
like that is that is what being an
artist an animator anyone that like is a
creator of things and stuff
and putting their imagination on the
world that that's what it's all about is
getting that image out of your head and
and videos and movies and tv shows are
just one aspect of that but it's one of
the most
i think in any way cohesive
methods of getting an imagination out of
your head you know if if you have
something that only you can see in your
mind and you can turn it into a reality
that's just a beautiful thing no matter
what it is but for me having a video
i see that you have commenced working
that you are a pressure washer yeah kind
of in the middle of a thought here kevin
bernard okay whatever
surely stacy doesn't theoristly think
that cleaning your carousel will make it
more practic attractive prospect than my
towering health or skelter i don't know
man what's a health or skelter what are
you talking about anyway
it's just it's wonderful i'm super happy
with it and i'm so glad that so many of
you enjoyed it and really took the
message to heart and really enjoyed just
the entire
show of it because it's like it's
massive and it's immense and there's so
much fun to it uh but it's special to me
because space is like special to me and
this show was
very special to me and it's probably the
last youtube original to be made and um
you know i'm glad that i was able to cap
it off
with that and now now i turn to kind of
like whatever the hell the next thing is
that i'm going to be doing
uh which is which is bizarre for a while
there even before it actually came out i
was just thinking to myself oh my god
what am i going to do next um and to be
perfectly honest uh the the vast
majority of it were probably oh
something bigger something better and to
be perfectly honest i i don't mind
better but just bigger oh my god no
god no way would i go for something
bigger than what i just did with space
um because that one was just
way way way too big
like pure and simple it was it was too
big it was too big in a way that was i'm
not just talking about the number of
videos or anything but the idea was too
grand
um not even two grand
like i'm i'm happy with how it came out
i'm saying two grand to keep doing it's
not the idea was too big it's too
idea is too big for me who wants to do
more things so uh the next few things
that i'm going to be doing are actually
going to be more contained uh more
isolated ideas that have
um
more of a condensed angle to them and
and i want to also
kind of like pick up with where youtube
originals left off and that i can help
other people make things i can help
other creators uh do stuff that they
want to do because that's what that in
my mind that's what youtube originals
was all about and yes i'm going to be
like kind of talking a little bit about
the behind the scenes of making things
with youtube originals and the flaws
therein i did not experience much of
them that other people did um you guys
might have seen dan howell's video about
working with youtube originals and and
to be perfectly honest like it wasn't
all sunshine and rainbows i was lucky
because i had complete creative control
with what i was doing other creators
were not so lucky to have that and
yes i am very grateful for my team that
i worked with at youtube originals and i
have nothing negative to say about them
but i i do know that youtube and google
as a whole is a big old corporation with
objectives and whatnot and and ideals
and goals and things that don't always
uh
don't always gel with what other people
want to do in terms of um making content
and especially when you're a creator and
you you have
like this chance to make something
wonderful and and you know
you know that you
are the only one this vision but you
don't necessarily know how this big
filming thing works when you work with a
professional crew and like in the in the
traditionally established film industry
of what it is it can be difficult to
navigate but i have now navigated it i
have now been through
every process of filmmaking i have
graduated from film school without ever
actually going to film school i'm not
saying film school is a waste but i have
done trial by combat of film school to
the point where i can confidently say
i know pretty much everything that film
school would ordinarily teach you and i
have done that through creating and let
me tell you there are some things that
you should definitely should go to film
school for if that is your objective
because uh to be perfectly honest there
a lot of it i had to learn on the fly
from people that went to film school i'm
not saying film school's useless but i
now confidently say i know enough
that i have an equivalent education
that's what i'm saying is i'm not saying
i'm better than anybody because i didn't
go to film school or i know
more than them i know as much as them
and there are still some things that i'm
lacking um but the basic principle what
i want to say is i can teach others i i
can teach others i can show other
creators what they can do with their
imagination and their vision and that's
kind of like what i want to be
i want to pick up with where youtube
originals left off i want to i want to
do this i want to help people make
things because
making things is kind of the most
beautiful part of youtube is you get to
put your imagination out there you get
to take risks and do things and you and
with technology these days like oh my
god the the technology that you have at
your fingertips is so much better than
it was even when i started youtube 10
years ago which can seem like a lifetime
ago and for some people i guess it is
you know um but when it comes down to
making things and learning all the
things that i've learned in the 10 years
and being able to leverage tools and
stuff like that it's
such an exciting time to make things and
i want people to realize that just
because youtube originals is gone does
not mean that i'm going to give up on
the idea that um
other people can make things and
creators can make things that are even
better than what people make on tv even
better than some movies that people make
they can
be made by individual creators and more
people need to understand that
more people need to realize that because
there is so much
so much an unbelievable amount of
potential in people that exist there in
the world you listening to this right
now
anybody that's watching my stuff needs
to know
there is no grand difference between you
and the people that make [ __ ] in
hollywood or india or korea or anything
like that the difference is they learned
enough to get there and if i can be a
teacher
for other people to make things and to
realize what they can do and with way
way way less of a budget than youtube
originals was chucking around you can
still execute really complex ideas it's
just about taking the time to learn and
plan and work and it's possible and i've
like
i've already got a few things underway
and i'm just like
wow i'm just super excited for it let me
use the new look oh that's very nice
you only use the new look mode
uh that's wonderful
i don't have to get dizzy going around
everywhere oh that's
so much nicer this is incredible i love
this
uh but yeah so i will oh i don't want to
do that yet i will definitely be oh
actually now would be a good time to
turn this bad boy on
now i could just
stand here and look
yeah let me just uh let me just blast
this for a bit um
that was quite nice yeah uh so i'm kind
of free again there's so many things
that i want to do and i want to be less
afraid to talk about these things
because that's been my life for so long
is like oh i can't tell you about these
secrets oh i can't tell you about all
these incredible things that i want to
do god i really just want to make power
wash simulator like my monday video
where i'm just able to talk about [ __ ]
because i don't i don't often just talk
i haven't done vlogs in a long long time
and that's practically all this is i
look at this as an excuse to be like
here's the here's what's going on in my
goddamn life
i'm so tired of like being secretive
there's so many things that i want to
tell you that i'm working on and and
plans and ambition
what i'm going to be doing is uh
in june you will see me in uh corridor
cruise videos because i am going i have
signed up to be corridor crews intern
for a month and then we're gonna see
where it goes from there but for
literally all of june i'm going to go
into the corridor crew office three
times a week and i'm going to help them
make videos
because i can and because i want to
learn because they are very good vfx
people and vfx is not my strong suit but
i want to learn these tools i want to
learn unreal engine 5 because there's so
much potential in what unreal engine 5
has to offer and in various gaming
engines as well there's so much that it
can do
that we can all learn from i just
realized that my
my nozzle is not long enough to get the
back wall so i've kind of been wasting
this opportunity
and honestly i should be using the green
one and just like go at it segmented but
yeah exactly
i
want to learn i still have so much to
learn
on youtube and i have so much to give
back because
apparently it was a surprise not to the
corridor people but to a lot of people
when i keep telling them that i wrote
all of space myself i did i wrote an
ungodly number of words something like
300 000 words total the script was 125
000 words it was all words but i wrote
them myself and there was some
duplication here and there but for the
most part that was a lot of writing and
to me it wasn't a surprise because of
course i had to write it because i had
to do it and and i want to i'm not a
great writer but i know how to do the
work you remember the unicornist video
where uh it was very early on i kicked
ethan in the balls but we were inflating
those big things you look at that and
that is a very pure example of what i'm
like if there's a tough route but it'll
get it done that's kind of just what i
do if i just need to blow it up with the
power of my lungs then i'm gonna blow it
up with the power of my lungs if we are
going to do a channel that requires us
to do a video every single day while
still running our own individual
channels i mean
[ __ ] man we're going to do it like
that's that's just how i am and that's
what i what i love about things and if
the best way for me to learn and also
get integrated into the wider youtube
world which is something that i have not
been a part of for a very long time
because i have been so isolated and with
kova did anything and also i've been
like up in my own ass about
being my own youtuber and trying to do
things on my own that i've often
forgotten that there are other youtubers
out there i don't really know what the
youtube landscape is outside of this i
know this can seem very strange
considering i am a very large youtuber i
have many many subscribers my channel
gets a lot of views but i talked about
this with anthony padilla if you didn't
see my video with him i also did a video
with bro you know i like i've done tons
of videos with other people lately
because
i don't know what's going on out there
in the youtube world for a platform that
i care about so much i know so little
about what is actually happening here
and so
i want to change that i just do i really
truly want to change uh this perception
that i have
about
my place in in youtube's world i don't
think of youtube as a competitive sphere
there are many youtubers and many people
out there watching this probably look at
youtube as a competitive place i have
never ever looked at it what please
check your job planner as a matter of
urgency what do you mean
[Music]
what
what
what do you mean why is that so scary
what do you mean
yes my helter sculptor is filthy
don't text me about your health or
skelter
is there something creepy that goes on
in the background of these videos
because i feel i feel like something
about this game is actually terrifying
and i don't know what it is yes this
will affect my performance oh are you
talking about your penis i really don't
want to hear about your penis now man i
was saying something that was kind of
important to me and i was like in the
middle of some but now you got this yes
the slide itself is beset with sticking
spots which take considerable arm
strength and willpower to get
all right go on i'm listening i am
listening what uh what do you have to
say about this
you have anything else is that all you
were gonna say okay i guess he's done
um but yeah if you watch the anthony
padilla video among other things that i
talk about it's like i
there's so many things that i don't know
is going on in the world but oh
competitive i'd have never viewed
youtube as a competitive platform where
if someone else gains something you lose
i have literally never looked at it that
way i do not believe that's how it is i
do not believe that the creative sphere
on the internet is a competitive place
where one person's gain is another
person's loss that's what i mean by
competitive you can be competitive like
i don't know race to be the first to
play a certain game or whatever but in
all honesty i would much rather look at
it as a collaborative place to see other
people's creations because once you get
past all these ideals and preconceived
notions of like oh the numbers and stuff
like that which i've left behind a long
time ago and it was incredibly healthy
for me to do that uh you start to
realize that everyone has individual
creativity and only the ideas that exist
in your head are yours and how you
execute upon those ideas will impact how
people receive them and how people see
it and how you view your own creative
potential so no it's not a it's not a
competitive platform the race is to the
top i have nothing against people doing
that either i don't care i did that one
time i'm over it at this point in my
life you know i have all these skills
and i know there's so much potential out
there and and it's dumb man i just want
to talk to people about it i just want
to talk to people about it this is why i
shoot the [ __ ] about a platform that i
really truly love and have not had a
chance to properly articulate my love
for
but i will i'm going to i'm going to now
because uh because i'm going to go crazy
if i don't right i i haven't talked to
you guys about anything
that i've been doing in my life
for so long for so long i do like a vlog
update you know honestly i kind of want
to make this my vlog series it's like uh
some people do videos i mean not anymore
but you know cs go surfing and [ __ ] like
this this is my version of that because
it's just incredibly satisfying
just i love this this one's actually
kind of nice just the way it kind of
rotates itself but uh
one would one might consider this to be
cheating but uh thankfully i do not i
haven't talked to you guys about like my
recent things with adhd oh i was talking
to my members so thank you again all the
members for being a part of the channel
um but i was talking to members and ever
since i i've kind of been a little more
open in talking about the fact that i
have adhd some of you listening to this
might find that as a bit of a surprise
but i have adhd and if you've been
listening to distractible which also is
something that i recommend you listen to
you might have heard my recent episode
about my cvs escapades and how it's been
very troublesome um but yeah i was
talking to my members and they i was
actually surprised by how many people
were really interested in me talking
about adhd more and more openly and what
it's like my struggles with adhd
the ways i
address it and try to like counteract
some of the more negative effects of
adhd
and stuff like that and i would love to
be more open about it if you guys uh
would like to and if you want to hear
about my my recent adventures in trying
to get a new prescription called the
stars uh
like prescribe to me and actually get it
it's there's a very funny but also very
frustrating story about my
my uh my arguments with cvs if you were
following me on twitter you might have
seen a while back i publicly tweeted
that was about getting this um but i'm
happy to say
it was it was just a matter of my local
summary and now you go listen to the
story if you want to listen to it but
but in all honesty one of the biggest
changes in my life that's really helped
out is is getting this new medication
and switching for my old one because i
used to take adderall and just being
able to sleep and you have no idea how
much just being able to sleep has helped
my mood and my mental faculties and my
ability to concentrate among many other
things like the medication's good and it
helps me uh but in terms of just like
these kind of like thoughts i've had
about life and where i'm going on
youtube and what i'm doing and and i
don't have worries about i'm just like
ooh what's next i definitely don't want
to sequester myself away for four years
to work on various projects one after
another no but what is next you know
what am i gonna do what am i gonna try
to do what am i gonna accomplish you
know i have ambitions i do i i've never
stopped having ambitions just because i
say
youtube isn't a competitive sphere by
default doesn't mean that i am not a
competitive person i am actually an
incredibly competitive person it's uh
it's in many parts of uh who i am or
based in my ability uh to channel [ __ ]
you energy i really love [ __ ] you energy
i love proven people wrong i love that
[ __ ] um as much as i love helping people
you know it's a it's a duality of me
and um i wouldn't have it any other way
but just like i want to be more open
with it i wanna i have to god i have to
be it's just i can't keep sprinting from
one project to another i just can't
because i
then i like commit to something that's
gonna take me two years and i i two
years i can't tell you what i'm doing
because it's all a big secret and then
nothing comes out for a while and then
you know videos will get scattered or
whatever and but you know i've been
super lucky in that you guys generally
understand that if i am not talking it
is because i am working on something
pretty cool and then you will see the
fruits of my labor
when it is ready but i don't want to do
that anymore i want to tell you guys
about what i'm doing i want to want you
guys to understand i want you to
understand why i'm excited
oh
unfortunately as we were winding through
wall of crete we encountered a group of
monks walking against the traffic and i
pressed the accelerator oh god you ran
over a group of monks
me
my jeet kune do instructor always says
in an emergency hit the nearest thing as
hard as you can what do you mean
what are you admitting to me right now
did you just did you run over a group of
monks
kevin
kevin did you run over a group of monks
please kevin tell me you didn't run over
a group of monks
i have to clean the inside now
why am wham i'll do the look mode oh
that's much better and much less
nauseating i bet for you guys
wow look at that i just want to tell you
guys about what's on my mind i wanna
make a film i wanna make an actual like
film film not for the sake of like oh
i've always wanted to make a movie nah i
wanna make a film because i wanna submit
it to a film festival and be like see
[ __ ] i can do this [ __ ] you have so
many of my uh so many of my competitive
[ __ ] you energy moments are from people
in traditionally established medias
thinking that we
youtubers creators like us can't make
[ __ ] as well as them it's like no we can
make [ __ ] as well as you and better so i
want to make a film festival movie i
want to put in a film festival just to
prove like hey hey guess what
i'm better than you literally when i say
that i'm like i'm a better person i am
but it's just like i like i like
harmless [ __ ] like that because who
gives a [ __ ] what a lot of those people
think some of them you know i like i've
met i've met quite a few people in that
world usually now i'm not talking about
like the crew i'm talking about like
think of like mega corporation style
uh media executives that do all this
stuff about like that make movies that
suck because they have not a creative
bone in their body you know that make
these horrible business decisions to not
put creative ideas out there you know
there's a lot of that now that i can be
like i can stand toe to toe with you
guys and that's one of the reasons why
i'm so happy about space is because it's
like a showcase of like yeah i can do
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah i can do really cool
[ __ ] i can do like fantastical cool [ __ ]
and if you're sleeping on the idea of
like internet as a vehicle for your
stuff and you're thinking in the same
same stupid boxes you've been thinking
of forever in terms of like how people
watch stuff on the internet like how how
people enjoy videos is like
you're gonna miss out because there's
people like me that are going to show
you how it's done and they're gonna do
it better and it's because i man i'm
just in a position to be able to do that
now and i want other youtubers to know
like yeah
you can do all of it you could do all of
it and more so i want to make a film
festival movie just to say [ __ ] you tall
them
kind of i know it's like a pissing
contest like a dick measuring contest
but at the same time it's like it
wouldn't be that hard for me to do
because i've done bigger more stuff i've
done space that is a that is about six
hours six hours and 50 something minutes
of content that's more than a movie i
know how long it took me to do that and
there was so many vfx shots if i made a
movie with like way less vfx shots i
would be able to make it for way less
money whale of like
all of it i would be able to do so much
for so much less in so much of a quicker
time
because i know what i'm capable of and i
know the quality that'll come out of it
i know these things i just
know them and so because i know them
i'm going to teach other people how to
know them and and i hope none of you
think that i'm speaking from a place of
arrogance i can
come across as egotistical and i'm sure
and it doesn't bother me if you think
that that's fine but i'm speaking and i
hope you understand that i am speaking
from experience now and that's what i
can really say confidently is that like
i do have experience i do know what i'm
talking about i can do the things that i
am saying i can put my money where my
mouth is and
like my god i am going to and i can make
other youtubers not make them like i can
show other youtubers
exactly the same
thing
there is a way this is like my big
ambition this is probably like my next
big ambition is other youtubers is being
like you can do it
you got it buddy you can do it so i'm
gonna again i'm gonna put my money where
my mouth is in terms of that too
and i'm going to show all of them
that it can be fun at the same time
because uh if you're not having fun
like what is the point sorry i got a
little heated about that i i didn't
realize how passionate i was about this
but this because i never had a chance to
talk about any of it i just never have a
chance to talk i just don't i don't know
why
but now i do
i mean i always have i just for some
reason and such especially like oh it's
better if it's a secret it's better of a
secret no it's better if people know
about it that way they can see it
they can see what's coming and i can
still make it hype without it being
super secretive but
teach their own and i've tried that and
i'm tired of it i'd rather i'd rather
just tell you guys what's going on so
you can be ready for it it seems to not
spoil the surprise anyway because you
seem to assume things that aren't even
there no matter what i say
no it's not honest it's starkiller at
the end of space you idiots i'm never
gonna forgive you guys for that i'm
never going to forget i matpat too i
couldn't believe it him too
was also like what could that be no
no you fool
it could not be
why he's dead
he's d-e-d dead never coming back the
whole point of unizanas would be missed
if he ever came back therefore he is not
ever going to come back because ethan
and i have integrity
unlike some people
matthew
patrick or should i say mac
i'm sorry there's a lot of really
talented people on youtube that's the
craziest thing is like there's so many
really talented people
they don't even realize it
but i will i'm going to exploit that not
exploit for my own benefit i'm going to
explain for their benefit i'm going to
cherishably exploit people
i'm gonna use them for their own good
[Music]
yeah do i seem evil is this is this how
cults start okay anyway i'm gonna use
people for their own good i'm going to
hold their hand i wa amy once amy said
as i was talking about this stuff baby
said uh i am like the pi i'm gonna be
like the pied piper of content
i'm just gonna be like
come with me
and you'll see
and i'm like that is a really good
compliment i hope that someday i could
be remembered as the pied piper of
content
that seems like a really nice
nice way to be remembered you know a lot
better ways there's a lot worse ways to
be remembered as a youtuber you know
when careers start to go downhill uh you
know things can go awfully poorly for uh
certain people as they start grasping to
hold on to something and uh you know i'd
like i'd rather my legacy be the pied
piper of content if i could do that but
also at the same time i have many
ambitions for my own content of with
which i shall show you guys in the very
near future god i hope you like audio
dramas
i want to do i want to do my own uh not
edge asleep but i want to do something
in the same style of edge of sleep in
terms of an audio show um because audio
and not having to film it means that i
can get a story out pretty quickly so i
would love to do like a multi-episode um
podcast story uh if you haven't listened
to edge of sleep i recommend you would
because season two got announced and is
like actually happening i have no news
on the tv show that's not me being
secretive it's literally just like
i have no news there is no news yet that
i am legally allowed to share so uh in
the meantime go listen to uh edge of
sleep the podcast
and then also be on the lookout for edge
of sleep season 2 of the podcast as you
wait for the tv show and if you didn't
know yes we filmed a tv show last year
in canada
another one of the many secretive things
that i just ran off
into the sunset for and then suddenly
came back from and then didn't know what
ever heard anything about which is some
a pattern that i'm kind of sick of at
this point i'm really sick of going to
do cool [ __ ] and then not say a goddamn
thing about it
that's what i am sick of
so i'm going to change that hey 69 clean
nice i don't know why i wasn't doing
look mode god i keep forgetting about it
i know it can be more nauseating but
whatever
whatever
all right that's looking pretty good for
now i need to
wow look at you why would i place you
why would i have any desired
wait a minute
huh
what
oh that's right i'm protecting uh my van
or the identity because i can't tell
people uh he doesn't want people to know
what i'm doing but also
i still think that there's something
very shady going on in this game and
they are not telling all the secrets
that they should tell and there is a
darkness within this place
and it will be revealed at some point in
the what are those are those eggs
[Music]
i don't know what those are
i didn't like them though why is this
area so big
why is any part of this the way it is it
doesn't have to be this way
okay whatever it's probably fine
i think
i hope anyway
back to cleaning the rest of this thing
let me get this super long
i can't wait to get that new hose it
costs five thousand dollars though i
think at one point i might have had
money but i no longer have money so when
uh
money's not really my thing
you know what i mean
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god i've been silent for so long
i don't know when i stopped talking
i uh that's the thing about this game is
like i'll just i'll completely get lost
in the um
the act of the wash and uh i don't know
it's just something very soothing about
it also i was literally like thinking
more about this idea of like bringing
people on
uh to do like
it doesn't have to be a podcast but if i
was able to just do like more
collaborations with other people and
just i bring them on and literally my
contingency for uh doing a video with me
is you have to play power wash simulator
with me and that way like we'll just
load up a map and we'll we'll just
cooperatively uh power wash and that's
how i do it [ __ ] it i'll interview
anybody i'll i'll make it like a talkie
series i love talking everyone probably
knows i like talking but uh if that's
something that you guys would actually
like to see let me know about that
because um
to be perfectly honest like the more i
think about it it may not be like a
forever thing but then again i am want
to uh want w-o-n-t to um start things
and then never finish it so uh it's not
exactly out of character for me to do
that so yeah what's the finish maybe i
should just do it [ __ ] it
you know what i'm gonna do it who would
you like to see me uh interview quote
unquote of of anyone doesn't have to be
a youtuber just like anybody there's
someone i could sit and chat with or
maybe i should think about that because
it's like i don't know it's cool who do
i want to talk to it's not about you
it's not about you you tell me whether
you'd like to see it and then i'll just
ignore your comments and decide whether
whether i do it for myself how about
that how's that sound like a deal does
that sound like our normal arrangement
[Music]
[Music]
finally starting to get these horse rods
and those have been the biggest pain in
the dick this whole entire time
they just don't want to get clean
okay
that's looking pretty good 79 i think i
got to get up on top of this bad boy now
oh
so let's try one of these maybe i could
jump up on top of it if i need to
oh right the twirly doo i forgot about
the turbo jet
not that i need it really not that i've
ever liked it anyway it's like kind of i
guess you know i could see the appeal of
it i really can because it really gets
in there and it really
scrubs out the deep
dirt that's really hard to get so maybe
it'll save you a couple passes
i don't know something about it just
isn't as satisfying to me
and that's the point of this game right
you play it because it's satisfying you
don't play it to win it getting clean
the fastest i'm not here to speedrun
even though i have tried although my
shrew like reflexes save the lives of
the monks my helter skelter fell off the
toe and rolled
oh
okay
i see i thought you killed a bunch of
monks that were trying to cross the road
that's what i did bad news it's covered
in everything from tertiary chalk to
permian mudstone
right well that sounds like a you
problem buddy
what are you uh
trying to talk to me about it for i
can't help you
see how is that any more satisfying than
this getting these stripes of clean oh
that's where the good stuff is
love look mode love look mode glad thing
they good glad thing they told me about
it can you imagine if they didn't tell
me about this ugh that would be their
fault
that would be their fault
[Music]
it is good for tickling these uh hard to
reach spots element and it does look
like i'm gucci gucci star
gucci
gucci gucci
i do get a little impatient sometimes i
will admit
but that's why i play this game because
it's a lesson in patience
and even the most impatient people can
learn a bit of patience
that's what i've learned
oh god
i've been playing this a long time i
always just get lost in the time vacuum
when i play this
always every time ha
wow that's a perfect shadow
but that's a good thing sometimes anyway
uh why is it green i just noticed that
it's kind of green oh god
where did you find this thing how do
these things in this town get so goddamn
dirty they just shouldn't be able to be
this dirty this shouldn't be a thing
oh minecraft oof
[Music]
god i love the turbojet actually
it does make life a lot easier
but conditionally
conditionally easier
[Music]
i can't really say that it's any better
than the regular old turbojet
[Music]
[Music]
oh i love the i actually didn't even
notice that these were in sections like
long tubes oh
if i hadn't known that i would have been
oh i would have been doing it by section
oh
that's okay
it's fine i'm not bitter
it's fine
i know there's some spots also down
inside that i probably missed but i'll
get there eventually i still don't know
what that weird message was about
looking at my eye cleaning list because
i don't even know what that is maybe
because the developers didn't give me a
tutorial button to teach me what it was
but i'm gonna blame the developers no
matter what so it doesn't matter what
they say it's their fault they made the
game they should know better they should
know that someone like me was gonna come
in here and wreck up the place they
should know that i was gonna ruin
everything they should know and it's
their fault
all right i think that's most of the top
the cresting still needs some doing
all of these crestings look like they
need some doing
um must have missed a spot towards the
either the underside or like some other
part that i'm not seeing oh i bet the
top of that gold i bet yeah no
uh there's some over there ah all right
it's just a few spots here and there
that i missed i probably need to bring
this thing around to do that but
let's see if i can get it from a
distance because i'm lazy
yeah it's not gonna happen
get what we can
i don't know if we're gonna be able to
get any more grab ladder
wham
[Music]
okay center pole frames
center pole ring center pole topper easy
peasy
uh rings ah here we go
just a few more to mop up here and then
that's the end i know towards the end of
this i kind of just like zoned out and
started cleaning but that's kind of the
beauty of the game isn't it
[Music]
oh
boy look at me go i got a body now
wow
that's a longer time lapse too
i'm flying
[Laughter]
my god that was fun carousel looks
incredible the others are going to lose
it when they see it i can practically
smell all that hard cash in my hands
already thanks so much you're welcome
what's next clean the drill i'll save it
i'll save it for now i want to see um
real quick before i go i just kind of
want to like know what
ah no i need friends thank you everybody
so much for watching if you do want to
see these future things where i'm
talking to other people and watching
cars uh let me know i kind of am
interested in seeing how that would be
so thank you
and as always
i will see you
in the next video
oh before i go uh i did mention a lot of
things i mentioned my videos with other
youtubers i mentioned my podcast with
bob and wade and tyler for go my
favorite sports team i mentioned all in
space with markiplier i don't have room
in the description to put all those
links but why not check them out on my
channel on other people's channels just
go and explore i'm going to be showing
up in a lot of places that you might not
expect very soon so thank you and as
always i'll see you in the next one
bye-bye
[Music]
you